al menos un misil ha impactado contra
este parque aquí donde nos encontramos
en la ciudad de jarc y la segunda ciudad
más importante del país está ubicada en
el este de ucrania hemos visto una mujer
herida una señora que se encontraba
paseando por este lugar esto también
muestra como los misiles están cayendo
no sobre objetivos estratégicos sino
sobre sitios como este donde pasean
ciudadanos pero también hemos visto a
los servicios de urgencia a los bomberos
intentará controlar los tres incendios
que provocaron provocó este nuevo ataque
que se produjo sobre la ciudad de
kharkiv una ciudad de que ucrania no
puede permitirse de perder sobre todo
después la caída de mariupol una
estratégica ciudad portuaria que ya se
encuentra bajo control ruso desde hace
varias semanas